[Musik]
sie haben mir gesagt ich habe einen
teufel in mir das hat mir angst gemacht
und diese angst haben sie ausgenutzt
sie predigt immer wir sind ein
göttliches projekt und wir gehen da raus
in die welt und hier wird etwas komplett
neues geboren
das sogenannte göttliche projekt liegt
im ländlichen brandenburg das
gesundheitshaus metatron ganz in der
nähe behandelt die leiterin des
gesundheitshauses in einem kinderheim
auch schwerst traumatisierte kinder mit
schamanischen ritualen einer der
jahrelang im gesundheitshaus metatron
gelebt hat wendet sich an uns und
berichtet von seinen erlebnissen
es ist ein auch vom verbalen angriffen
teilweise sind körperlich angegriffen
das ist jemand dann halt offen vor der
gesamten gruppe beauftragt wird oder vor
die wand geschubst oder auf dem boden
geschubst werden oder was auch immer
kann das sein wir wollen mehr erfahren
vereinbaren eintreffen
auch wenn er die jahre die er bei
metatron war hinter sich lassen will
möchte er vor der gruppe waren so sagt
er uns vor allem die situation im
nahegelegenen kinderheim bereite ihm
sorgen ich bin davon schwer überzeugt
dass die kinder da auch schäden
davontragen mit sicherheit weil sie
absolut auch schon in einer blase
aufwachsen und mit schamanischen
ritualen und aufstellung seminaren ganz
zu schweigen er sorgt sich dass die
kinder als nachwuchs für die metro
gruppe rekrutiert werden könnten
die sei wie eine sekte sagt er uns er
selbst habe den ausstieg erst nach
mehreren versuchen geschafft es sei sehr
schwer gewesen
also es gibt die tendenz den kontakt zu
freunden oder zu verwandten
einzuschränken die die wenigen die dann
tatsächlich regelmäßig und viel kontakt
ins außen was ist immer so ein
feststehender begriff ins außen haben
weihnachten zum beispiel komplett bei
der familie verbringen oder so was sie
werden regelrecht gemobbt wir wollen
wissen ob die vorwürfe stimmen
einmal im monat findet bei der metatron
gruppe ein sogenannter vereinstag stadt
eine art tag der offenen tür
wir fahren hin und geben uns als
interessierte aus das was wir erleben
stellen wir nach der erste programmpunkt
klingt harmlos ein kräuter nachmittag
zum thema ev uns wird versichert efeu
habe große heilkräfte wir fragen nach
bei welchen erkrankungen hilft den vfl
bei alkoholismus und krebs danach lernen
wir die leiterin des gesundheitshauses
kennen sie kommt auf das naheliegende
kinderheim zu sprechen wo sie kinder
behandelt wir haben ganz schwere fälle
da misshandelte kinder sexuelle gewalt
wir haben durchgesetzt dass sie keine
medikamente kriegen sondern homöopathie
ich arbeite mit denen auch spanisch sie
lädt uns ein an dem nächsten
programmpunkt teilzunehmen
eine familienaufstellung die leiterin
führt uns echte patienten zu und es geht
um deren zum teil schwerste krankheiten
und probleme
dabei sind wir können doch für die
leiterin ist das kein problem
ihr seid ja neu hier wir haben übrigens
nur zwei tabus keiner wird umgebracht
und kein sex so jetzt starten wir im
laufe der familienaufstellung weitere
einblicke in ihre welt anschauen wenn
jüngere menschen sterben ist es ja das
ist ihr karma das ist so vorbestimmt
dass sie sterben tod und krankheit als
vorgezeichnet es schicksal
keiner hier stellt die leiterin des
gesundheitshauses und solche aussagen in
frage ihr dürft nicht so ins opfer gehen
ihr seid für eure krankheiten selbst
verantwortlich nach sieben stunden
verlassen wir die metatron gruppe mit
gemischten gefühlen und vielen
unbeantworteten fragen wird den menschen
im gesundheitshaus geholfen oder ihre
situation nur ausgenutzt
wir recherchieren weiter stoßen auf
einen krebspatienten der im
gesundheitshaus hilfe gesucht hat er
möchte anonym bleiben berichtet von
ausstellungen bei denen er von der
metatron leiterin unter druck gesetzt
worden sei auf arztbesuche zu verzichten
mir wurde gesagt dass ich nur das machen
soll was die metatron leiterin mir vor
gibt sonst nämlich ihre arbeit nicht
ernst und wenn ich schulmedizinische
behandlungen mache habe ich keine chance
und werde sterben im letzten augenblick
habe er den absprung geschafft und sich
ärztliche hilfe geholt
wir wollen mit der leiterin über die
vorwürfe sprechen bitten um ein
interview bekommen jedoch keine antwort
und konfrontieren sie direkt was sagen
sie zu den vorwürfen dass hier menschen
von ärztlicher behandlungen abgeraten
oder was sagen sie zu den vorwürfen dass
hier körperliche gewalt und psychische
gewalt gegen patienten verwendet wird es
gibt leute die sagen dass sie ihm davon
abraten sich ärztlich gegen krebs
behandeln zu lassen
was jetzt fühlen
das ist wahr
weitere fragen möchte die leiterin des
gesundheitshauses nicht beantworten
dabei hätten wir gerne mit ihr über das
nahe gelegene kinderheim gesprochen
was hat es mit den schamanischen
ritualen auf sich die sie dort wie sie
uns selbst offenbart hatte mit den
kindern durchführt im netz finden wir
informationen zum kanal aufgeteilt auf
zwei häuser leben hier kinder im alter
zwischen vier und zwölf jahren
viele von ihnen haben traumatische
erfahrungen gemacht gewalt missbrauch
vernachlässigung
geleitet wird das heim von einem ehepaar
die frau ist die tochter der leiterin
des gesundheitshauses und fast alle
mitarbeiter des kinderheims sind auch
teil der metatron gruppe auch unser
informant half einmal wöchentlich im
kinderheim haus sagt er
wir treffen ihn noch einmal wollen
wissen wie er das erlebt hat ja ganz
konkret was ich erlebt habe dass ich auf
dem kind drauf gelegt worden ist weil er
einen aggressiven ausfall hatte wirklich
die idee überhaupt kommt von werbe
prenzel hermansen sich auf kinder zu
legen wenn es probleme gebe wenn es
schreien würde wenn es laut hürde wenn
es um soziales verhalten zeigen würde
da gab es diverse situationen und eben
den seminaren hat zuerst immer wieder
einfach gesagt sie sagt ja auch ne
seminaren offen dass man die kinder
schlagen soll
ein klaps sahin scholl ich stimmen diese
vorwürfe wir wollen dem nachgehen
bewerben uns im kinderheim als
praktikantin geben vor studentin der
erziehungswissenschaften zu sein drehen
verdeckt beim einarbeitungs gespräch
ohne unsere personalien oder
qualifikationen zu überprüfen werden dir
angenommen im einarbeitungs gespräch
kommt die heimleitung gleich zur sache
wir haben ganz schwere fälle
misshandelte kinder sexuelle gewalt
aber wir haben durchgesetzt dass die
keine medikamente kriegen sondern
homöopathie
meine mutter arbeitet mit denen auch
schamanische schamanismus läuft viel
über bilder
da gibt es ganz viele formate zum
beispiel seelen rückführungen ich mir
fehlen die worte was dann diese form von
seelen was sie zählen rückführung
bedeutet das ist mir schleierhaft und
das hat überhaupt nichts mehr mit
seriöser pädagogik zu tun
es dürfte überhaupt nicht im rahmen der
öffentlichen jugendhilfe so etwas
praktiziert werden die psychologin
irmela wiemann ist spezialisiert auf die
therapie von pflegekindern und hält
fachseminare zur heimunterbringung im
gesamten deutschsprachigen raum
wir zeigen ihr vieh aussagen der
heimleitung sollen wir im umgang mit den
kindern auf irgendetwas besonders achten
auf triggerpunkte oder so viele
heimkinder werden in watte gepackt das
machen wir nicht wir konfrontieren
heimkinder mit der energie mit der sie
uns gegenüber treten mit der gleichen
energie mit der gleichen kraft man kann
nichts falsch machen
zur professionellen trauma pädagogischen
heim erziehung gehört ist dass wir
träger vermeiden ich muss wissen was ich
tue und ob ich mit einem bestimmten
verhalten ein kind in not bringen
zurück ins kino die heimleitung erklärt
uns den vermeintlichen praktikantin am
beispiel eines mädchens das sexuelle
gewalt erfahren hat wie mit den kindern
umgegangen wird
1 von den kindern spielt das ist für uns
ein zeichen dass die ordnung verquer ist
sie ist hyperaktiv hat reduzierte
schmerzempfinden
ich hatte zwei situationen wo ich auf
sie drauf gesprungen bin
um sie zu erden drauf gelegt weil sie
fängt dann auch an ein zu beschimpfen
und zu schmeißen
und da hilft nur körper betreuer die
sich auf kinder drauf legen
von solchen methoden berichtet auch der
ehemalige metatron bewohner
ich habe es kaum ausgehalten dabei zu
sein das mit anzusehen dass das dem kind
dann quasi angetan worden ist und sie
hat aber auch nicht nachgelassen und bis
das kind dann irgendwann still waren und
so lange auf dem kind drauf gelegen
gerade bei kindern die traumatisiert
wurden die ich schon ausgeliefert waren
und ohnmächtig waren und todesangst
hatten die geraten wieder in todesangst
und solche menschen die das anwenden die
die sagen dann hinterher oh das wirkt
das kind ist jetzt so zahm und das ist
so freundlich aber eigentlich hat man
den willen gebrochen wenn das in der
öffentlichen jugendhilfe passiert dann
ist das ein großer skandal
wir wollen mit der leitung des
kinderheims über die vorwürfe sprechen
ein interview wird abgelehnt
auf unsere schriftliche fragen teilt man
uns mit
wir sehen keine veranlassung unser
pädagogisches und therapeutisches
konzept in die öffentlichkeit zu tragen
geschweige denn stellung zu beziehen
oder irgendetwas zu verteidigen als ein
heim mit solch einem verqueren
irrationalen konzept das überhaupt alle
pädagogischen grundlagen entbehrt darf
im grunde genommen nicht bewilligt
werden darf eigentlich nicht
weiterarbeiten da müsste sofort die
heimaufsicht einschreiten wir fragen
nach beim jugendamt schriftlich erklärt
man uns die behörde sehe keinen
handlungsbedarf
zitat die konzeptionelle ausrichtung
entspricht den sozialpädagogischen
anforderungen und weiter homöopathische
oder schamanische bezüge als ergänzender
leistungsbereich zu einem konzept im
sinne der jugendhilfe sind zulässig
entsprechende denkansätze und haltungen
können mit der arbeit einhergehen sie
stellen keine kindeswohlgefährdung dar
und findet es die behörde auch zulässig
sich auf kinder drauf zu legen
die zeugenaussagen sind uns nicht
bekannt
es kann daher nicht dazu stellung
genommen werden und so müssen
traumatisierte kinder wohl weiter
aushalten dass man sich auf sie drauf
legt wir haben bei der leitung des
kinderheims nachgefragt ob sie etwas an
ihren umstrittenen methoden verändert
haben keine antwort
[Musik]